on parle pas assez de pauvreté dans
notre pays on ne parle pas assez de ceux
qui sont dans la misère qu ont du mal à
boucler les fins de mois qu'on a du mal
à manger normalement coin du mal à se
loger
il faudrait qu'on arrête 7 jours sur 7
de parler de immigration islam banlieue
comme par les deux jours sur 7
mais c'est pas mal que 5 jours sur 7 on
parle aussi de ses problématiques
sérieuse structurante de la société
française or ces sujets on n'en parle
jamais je trouve que c'est
catastrophique
il faut que ce soit la crise sanitaire
de l'aco vide qui met le focus sur des
femmes et des hommes qui n'arrivent pas
à manger deux fois par jour dans notre
pays on est la france le président la
république utilise une expression qui
qui qui était très patriotique
patriotique nous sommes la france
ok puisque nous sommes la france on doit
tous s'interroger quel que soit notre
sensibilité est ce acceptable d'avoir
une femme qui gagne 150 euros par mois
un homme qui gagnent 330 euros par mois
dans un pays comme la france un pays qui
déjà fait beaucoup sur le plan social
qui a une capacité en matière de santé
doit être présent contrairement aux
états unis qui naissent 40 millions de
pauvres sur le bord du chemin qui ne
peut pas soigner
donc on a déjà un acquis on a un
potentiel on a je dirais un actif mais
il ne faut pas qu'on dorme concentre
donc sur nos lauriers sur nos acquis il
faut qu'on commette si l'accent sur ces
femmes et ces hommes de plus en plus
nombreux depuis la crise de la commune
un million et demi de plus nos pauvres
dans notre pays
sept cent mille emplois détruits on a
trois cent mille commerce non
alimentaire aujourd'hui qui sont fermés
si on multiplie par cinq environ
ça fait un million et demi de salariés
parce que ce sont des petites
entreprises de moins de dix salariés
pour la plupart par foyer même parfois
une assiette y en a 8 mai c'est le tissu
économique du pays ça on a deux millions
huit cent mille entreprises de moins de
20 salariés dans le pays
donc c'est notre tissu économique
aujourd'hui ce tissu économique on a
tiré le rideau
au moins je vais vous dire c'est par ses
pas on vous attaque pas quand on pose
j'avais dû lire un esprit critique je
veux pas madame la ministre que vous le
preniez comme ça
tout à l'heure le premier ministre il a
appris apa il a dit ne vous trompez pas
d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est le virus est
pas votre gouvernement je suis désolé
c'est pas le sujet d'ennemis on a comme
disait condorcet un esprit critique on a
le droit de penser on a le droit de vous
dit on à le droit de vous apporter aussi
notre avis des propositions sans vous
agresser et en l'occurrence si sur le
plan économique
je trouve que notre pays a fait
peut-être ce que aucun pays a fait dans
le monde
chômage partiel mais ge sont les prêts
garantis par l'état donc une dizaine de
10000 euros là de que que vous avez
annoncé des aides de 500 euros pour
construire un site de dz 2500 euros pour
des professions libérales
il y à des aides dans notre pays
effectivement donc qui peut vous faut
peut-être mieux communiquer plus
communiquer pour que les femmes et les
hommes en difficulté puissent en
disposer
mais on n'est pas absent de ce côté là
en revanche sur la crise sanitaire
moi j'ai envie de vous dire que depuis
le départ j'ai l'impression qu'on court
derrière le virus et qu'on n'arrive pas
anticipé on a une pénurie de marque de
masques au mois de mars
on nous a dit le masque est pas utile or
on avait une pénurie nous n'avions pas
même si on nous avait décrété que le
masque était utile nous n'en avions pas
la séquence de ça a été les tests ont
fait un million de tests par semaine me
chope en trois jours pour un rendez-vous
et trois jours pour voir le résultat
or six jours après ça sert à rien parce
que les cas contacts vous en avez fait
des dizaines autour de vous le test il
est efficace quand vous l'avez dans les
48 heures et que vous êtes isolé là
aujourd'hui on a les tests antigénique
en 15 minutes 30 minutes c'est très bien
force est de constater que ça arrive au
tard on est au mois de novembre
donc j'ai l'impression qu'on court
derrière ensuite on a du couvre feu
court au feu les français le respecte le
fassions respecter le port du masque les
français respectent un confinement
je pense que les français les français
respectent je pense que les français les
français sont conscients de la gravité
de la crise en revanche un petit
problème de cohérence franc je maintiens
que sur les petits commerces
je le maintiens je lui maintiens et
s'est pas encore une fois pour fait par
plaisir pourtant d'accord avec vous il
ya un enjeu social qui coïncide érable
madame la nuit
il faut savoir que la mort sociale
aujourd'hui ça peut être la mort tout
court
quand on entend les plantations de
suicides chez beaucoup moi ça m'inquiète
profondément les pathologies
psychologiques que ça va générer donc
les
collatéraux monumentaux donc honnêtement
je pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut
s'interroger sur ce tissu économique à
qui on a demandé quand même de tirer le
rideau
bien vite les allemands ne l'ont pas
fait les allemands ont fait le
couvre-feu ça fonctionne
l'étude dont parlait monsieur ce bail
robert que je vous connais bien c'est un
gars brillant l'étude c'est 98 millions
d'américains qui ont été suivies ces
jeunes joueurs c'est une revue
scientifique mondialement reconnu qui
nous dit quoi
les petits commerces ne sont pas la
cause de la contamination et du
développement du virus
quand on a une étude sur cinq millions
de personnes comment se fait-il qu'on ne
puisse pas réajusté s'adapter pourquoi
autant de psycho rigidité
encore une fois mon jour mon petit
coiffeur alexandre ii que qui vous a
bien réussi d'ailleurs merci glace je
vais faire des tests à ses employés il
porte le masque
il fait des rendez vous est ce pas c'est
pareil pour le cordonnier de que pareil
pour tous les petits commerçants ils
sont hyper sérieux les librairies pareil
et parfois madame la ministre
c'est la seule sortie pour quelqu'un qui
vit seule or c'est pas simplement le
réflexe du consommateur moi qui
m'intéresse c'est le lien social de ces
petits commerçants
le petit commerçant on lui parle ils
nous demandent de vos nouvelles
quand vous avez une personne qui est
seule chair qui confinait les trois
quarts de la journée et qui sort juste
pour aller dire bonjour je voudrais ce
livre là vous allez bien madame tout va
bien oui ça va montrer bien prenez soin
de vous c'est énorme
comment sait-il que dans notre grand
pays 7 sept
cette humanité donc on la prennent pas
en considération dans un contexte pareil
encore une fois je pense que vous
n'étiez pas loin d'avoir le bon curseur
vous n'étiez pas loin avant de conclure
sur moi j'ai mis ce qu'il fallait pas
des copines et parce que quand je vois
les centres de ranimation saturé quand
je vois ce personnel soignant qu'on
applaudit à 20 heures dont on a dit que
c'était des héros si on les respecte
oui on fait attention si on les respecte
oui on porte le masque si on les
respecte
on fait attention à nos nos grands mères
nos grands pères
ceux qui sont des vulnérables oui si on
les respecte et puis il ya eu 500 morts
par jour dans notre pays et on ne peut
pas se réjouir de ça parce que ça touche
pas que les autres ça peut toucher aussi
ses proches et cantonales un esprit de
solidarité
tout ça ça compte donc je ne suis pas
pour le des confirmands mais ça n'est
pas un confinement comme nous avait
proposé dans la séquence 2 parce que les
écoles sont ouvertes
parce qu'il ya 45 % des salariés du
privé de christian trois jours de
télétravail mais le reste ils vont au
bureau parce qu'on voit bien que dans la
rue c'est pas le mois de mars quand même
beaucoup plus de flux on devait demander
de fermer le restaurant là aussi madame
la ministre nous avions reçu avec cyril
des restaurateurs qui a une idée
plexiglas qui avait fait un sort de
ressort que 50% de leur clientèle donc
divisé par 2 qui avait tout réajustée la
rue a été sérieux est ce que vous avez
fait la part des choses entre les enyele
les autres ministres nom et est passé de
contrôle et vous avez mis tout le monde
dans le même sac
on ferme circulez ya rien à voir or je
pense que dans un cas pareil dans une
situation paris sion de concilier ces
insanités reste sur sur économique il
faut avoir un discours clair ceux qui
respectent les règles ce qui sauve
sérieux qui font en sorte effectivement
que le virus on puisse le contenir c'est
difficile
vous avez une position très difficile
cela on va pas leur mettre un coup sur
la tête on bat les idées et ce en
revanche qui prennent les choses un peu
à la légère et que soit laxiste
c'est pas 135 on va leur mettre
peut-être qu'il fallait la triple est
telle qu'il fallait la faire par dix la
demande mais faire la part des choses
entre ceux qui respectent et ceux qui
avaient fait des investissements ce qui
était sûr que ceux qui ont mis une vie
dans leur commerce pendant la ministre
une vie dans leur commerce et anna
toutes leurs économies ils ont ré est
notre toute leur vie se sont consacrés à
ça et vous leur dites mais on ne fait
pas la part des choses vous tire le
rideau
mais non il sait pas carrefour c'est pas
la farine quand même c'est pas darty ils
sont fragiles cela peut arriver si vous
pouviez simplement votre question pour
la revoir et ça me paraît clair ce tissu
économique d'abord je suis pas que dans
la question parce que je lui donne un
avis général
et puis je pense que vous avez compris
quand même qu'ils avaient un tissu
économique qui se sentaient sacrifier
ses gros comme le nez au milieu de la
figure
et encore une fois c'est mis un demi de
salariés on a eu millions de pauvres
supplémentaires cette famille
supprimez bon marché de casse les
scellés ouvert avec des dispositions
ils sont sérieux sais pas mais ça mais
vous l'avez très bien c'est que c'est
pas facile comme décision après des
jours on confine pas on compte les morts
on compte les séquelles pendant cette
émission il ya 30 personnes qui vont
mourir mais c'est bien la photo il ya 42
ministres sur les bars et les
restaurants sait pas alors j'ai entendu
de l'étude sur américaine que vous le
citez pardon mais il ya 40% des gens qui
ont moins de 65 ans ils sont dans les
réanimations donc c'est un vrai sujet
sérieux si on confine on et entraîne
effectivement de mettre en difficulté
des entreprises
on en est bien conscient moi j'ai été en
charge du petit commerce
j'étais en charge de l'artisanat mais ce
n'était toutefois cette étude deux
jeunes acteurs 98 je vais vous répondre
allez-y ce que je suis en train de faire
ce sur quoi on travaille avec bruno le
maire avec le patron des le miz et pme
alain griset ce sur quoi on travaille
c'est deux choses la première chose
c'est de même d aide massive massive se
remplace pas massive que le chiffre
d'affaires ou les bains quand vous
complété par charges fixes les loyers
company dans euro
dix mille euros c'est six fois ce qu'on
a mis au mois d'avril
et je peux vous dire une chose dix mille
euros avec 80 % des commerçants qui sont
en dessous de ça et je suis d'accord
si j'ai envie de baisser
il disait valéry alors on va juste
étudiants à aller jusqu'au bout
et la deuxième chose qu'on fait une
taupe c'est qu'on se donne ici c'est
qu'on se donne deux semaines justement
pour faire le maximum et pour donner la
lumière au bout du tunnel en dix ans le
1er décembre
il faut qu'on se batte pour vous rouvrir
avec les protocoles sanitaires qui vend
bien
ce serait il y avait tout respect déjà
seule barrière vous citer l'allemagne
ils n'ont pas tout à fait le même nombre
de malades en ce moment cno moi je peux
vous parler der land
je peux vous parler mais ce pagne je
peux vous parler la belgique dont tu
peux vous parler littaye le même nombre
de lits ou six ans no 28 1000e katona
ces minerais
ça on le sait donc effectivement ils ont
beaucoup plus testé que nous dès le
départ oui la méthode allemande n'est
pas la nôtre
mais les plus efficaces que la nôtre le
mentionne le montant total hors n'est
pas non plus le même les
individuellement 80 millions
un autre fonctionnement en attendant
tous nos voisins les plus proches à part
l'allemagne avait raison de souligner le
magazine allemand